my name is Jack Cooper and I'm no pilot  I was just in the right place at the  wrong time sometimes you don't get to  choose your path it chooses you BT  transferring authorization to do pilot I  am now linked to rival and Jack Cooper  but whether or not I was meant for this  doesn't matter because now we are all  that stands between salvation and  extinction the IMC have developed a  weapon it has the power to destroy  entire world  stand by for Heights all  he was never meant to be my Titan gonna  make it out of this BT King in to copy  my apartment I never planned to be his  pilots  I will not lose another pilot  stop you don't worry bTW I'm not going  anywhere  you